14 février 2018 nous sommes aux confins
de l'isère et de la savoie c'est l'hiver
il fait froid et les massifs et route de
montagne sont enneigées maylis a disparu
depuis cinq mois et demi et c'est le
jour où la sphère bascule le jour
nordahl landais passe aux aveux
ce soir ils savent
que leur fille est morte
un peu avant 8h ce matin là l'unique
suspect dans cette affaire est extrait
de sa prison de saint-quentin-fallavier
pour aller au palais de justice de
grenoble
nordahl le landais a rendez vous avec
les juges d'instruction en charge de la
faire c'est lui même qui demande à être
reçue juste après que son avocat lui
révèle l'existence d'une preuve
accablante contre lui
quelques jours plus tôt un rapport
d'expertisé scientifique est versée au
dossier l'audi a3 de le landais a été
désossée et malgré son nettoyage
minutieux de plus de deux heures au
lendemain de la disparition de l'enfant
quelque chose a été retrouvé sous le
tapis de sol du coffre c'est une
minuscule taches de sang une minuscule
taches de sang qui appartient à maylis
acculé le landais avoue lui qui clamait
son innocence depuis le début parfois
empêtré dans ses explications il
reconnaît avoir tué la petite fille de 9
ans involontairement involontairement
en larmes totalement anéanti selon son
avocat maître jacubowicz il présente des
excuses aux juges à maylis et aux
parents de la petite fille il refuse de
s'exprimer sur les circonstances exactes
de sa mort mais mène les enquêteurs sur
le trajet de cette nuit funèbre du 26 au
27 août 2009
il est alors conduit à pont de
beauvoisin à la salle polyvalente où
maylis a été vu pour la dernière fois
lors du mariage d'un cousin de ses
parents puis à domezain à 3,4 kilomètres
de là où vivait nordahl le landais chez
ses parents
il indique avoir déposé le corps de
malice avant de retourner au mariage
puis repartir le convoi se dirigeant fin
à une dizaine de kilomètres vers saint
francs villages du massif de la
chartreuse non loin des gorges de shay
[Musique]
un endroit où il ya de la forêt une
espèce de petit ravin un endroit
extrêmement reculé détails le procureur
nordahl le landais mais plusieurs heures
avant de retrouver le lieu exact où il a
abandonné le corps de la petite fille il
était certain du début de son trajet
mais pas de sa fin déclare son avocat le
convoi de plusieurs voitures s'arrêtent
sans cesse puis redémarre une déneigeuse
vient même ouvrir un sentiers encombrés
puis c'est à pied qui progresse menotté
et suivis pas à pas par les gendarmes
nordahl le landais s'immobilise près
d'un rocher je pense que c'est là
aurait-il dit avant de s'effondrer à
nouveau son avocat s'interroge pleurer
t-il sur son sort ou sur celui de sa
victime
c'est la fin de l'après midi et la nuit
commence à tomber les chiens piste enfin
les restes de maylis à crâne d'enfant et
un os nous sont retrouvés ça a été une
journée
dense une journée éprouvante et
innovantes pour tout le monde peu avant
23h la mère de miley ce poste un message
sur facebook il aura fallu attendre cinq
mois et demi pour que ce monstre parle
enfin toile assassins de ma fille maëlys
va te hanter nuit et jour
[Musique]